john wick you voted for it lots of
injuries lots of gore i'm gonna break it
down
be careful john
all right first concussion i feel like
he's gonna get concussed a lot here if
you're getting hit with a solid object
on the back of your skull ow that's
gonna cause a very serious injury not
only is he's gonna split your skull open
you're gonna start bleeding a lot but
also you're gonna get your brain rattled
that's a concussion
oh abdomen kick right into the solar
plexus ah knocks the wind right out of
you
oh
broken arm looks like right in the
humerus at least a bone bruise at least
oh kick in the face broken nose after
getting hit in the head with a baseball
bat he's out he's out cold
so this is the funny part about this
movie is they're supposed to be speaking
russian it's not russian folks i don't
know what he's saying see the fact that
his nose stopped bleeding here is also
not real like what made his nose stop
bleeding it would actually become a
problem because he's laying on his back
it's gonna go right into his oral cavity
he's gonna choke on it if he swallows it
it's gonna cause gi disturbance in him
he's gonna have diarrhea later on john
wick is suffering
this is like one of the most epic scenes
in this but there's like 400 people and
no one can hurt john wick
oh
i mean gsw's all day long like he's just
head shots like there's nothing you can
do there it's not something you're
getting up and he does parkour in his
spare time clearly
going through a true glass window is
actually really problematic because this
glass isn't the type of glass that's in
your windshield that shatters into tiny
little pieces the reason that it happens
here is because the movie makes it like
that in real life the glass can actually
shatter with big
big slices of glass that are sharp
sticking out that can sever a carotid
artery so it's never as clean as oh you
just jump through the window and the
whole thing just explodes
[Music]
the close quarters combat here is on
point
yeah getting stabbed in the heart
is a death
death death
death injury
pizza's here
pizza time
okay getting stabbed in the carotid will
make you bleed out very quickly
oh punch in the face
oh you look like right there that he
tore his mcl because he kicked the
outside of his leg a medial collateral
ligament just went and just popped
crawled
okay
see that whole cracking thing
i don't buy that i don't i know he's a
killer but he just kind of went like
this and that's not that's not deathly
enough
getting stabbed like that in the mouth
has got to be the most painful thing
ever you have so many nerve fibers in
your mouth in your tongue this is why
kissing feels good this is why you could
always feel a little blister in your
mouth or on your tongue that would be
just i would scream out of it oh once
yes yes okay good russian i feel like
this is also becoming a russian review
of john wick
the big dude's incoming
[Music]
i love that big dude got stabbed in the
shoulder and he eats it and then he
steps on his toe and the guy's like oh
okay i gotta give up
[Music]
this area here has a lot of cartilage
and if you break that cartilage it
becomes hard to swallow breathe oh
that's very very painful
i was gonna say the glass in his eye
could have become a problem because it
could have given him a corneal abrasion
but then he got shot in the head so that
negates that problem
this is i think his worst injury oh oh
getting thrown off the balcony like that
landing on the back there's a vertebral
fracture there there might even be a hip
fracture depending on how he landed on
his pelvis but again he's bulletproof
he's a doctor
yes sir 24 7. send him up please i'll be
right there may i suggest a drink i
would not
alcohol makes your clotting worse my man
is gonna bleed out keep the alcohol away
and keep the bleeding at bay oh
take two of these beforehand
and you'll bleed
but you'll have full function i'm
assuming he's giving him some kind of
amphetamine or something to keep his
pulse up because if you start bleeding
out and your blood pressure drops you're
gonna faint do you need anything for the
pain no i've got that covered
no just take a real pain medication
my man was just trying to get some sleep
to recover to allow his wounds to stop
bleeding i don't know why he has a sling
on if he has a fracture he needs a cast
that sling is not helping
clearly whatever was bothering him that
he needed a sling for was not true
considering my guy doesn't just takes
her right off and starts fighting
that was the least believable fight
sequence she just like flew off his back
and she just flew into the air come on
now
shot into the quad
oh she just dislocated her thumb ah
that's gotta hurt
is she gonna put her thumb back now yeah
i'm thinking i'm back i'm thinking i'm
back if i ever go on vacation from the
hospital i'm just gonna walk in i think
i'm back
yeah so suffocation is a big problem
he kicks him not to the point where he
falls but he kicks him to the point
where his legs go above his head just
like it's so not realistic
again they make a cracking noise like
he's cracking everyone's necks no
abdominal gsws are really a big problem
you can have bleeding into the
retroperitoneal space where you don't
even realize the person's losing a lot
of blood that's not only a painful
injury it's also a life-threatening
one not
he didn't say that he said like go f
yourself no guard
oh right in the quad the only thing is
he went straight down the middle there's
a femur in there and that bone is
stronger than concrete so you ain't
stabbing through no fever my friend
i mean blunt force trauma like that you
don't necessarily die from you get
knocked out you can get some internal
bleeding but you don't instant die
[Music]
that looks like what i open my mail time
videos with
[Music]
[Applause]
that was so unnecessary my guy stabs
himself just to dislocate his elbow and
it's not that easy to dislocate an elbow
especially when you've just been stabbed
one got stabbed in the abdomen one guy
stabbed in the jugular no one's winning
here everyone's just wet and dying
you might want to put some pressure on
that wound there buddy this is a animal
hospital i feel like the mafia movies
it's always an animal hospital you don't
need peroxide
just soapy water
this is so unnecessary and you got a
staple gun okay
i'm okay with that it auto folds in it
like clasps the tissue it's not ideal
you'd want to put sutures in they're a
little bit more flexible
if someone ever did something to bear
i have a special set of skills
those skills
require tools
i have access to those tools
[Music]
number one tool i like to use
scalpel
i know where to cut with that scalpel to
make sure that
whoever
did whatever they did to bear
will no longer be doing that to bears
again
i'll leave it at that
if you're over 18 click here for final
destination injury reviews click it
check it out it's gory it's crazy it
doesn't make sense click it
snappy and healthy but click it
[Music]
you